alright hello everyone and welcome
to the 4th speaker and our nature
culture action series I'd like to
introduce Professor Steven Stoll he
teaches at Fordham University in
Manhattan and the Bronx he researches
primarily agrarian societies in the
United States he is the author of the
book landing the earth and has also
written for Harper's and Orion ironing
the land I'm really sorry learning the
leaner Wow I cannot read my own
handwriting
I'm so sorry that's a better title
anyway okay he's gonna give a talk today
titled the captured gardens subsistence
under capitalism please welcome
professor so thanks could we lower it
like maybe just the lights right here so
that you can see the slides all right
how are you so what I wanted to do today
is make the argument to you that when
the mountain people of Appalachia
entered coal camps they didn't stop
growing their own food and that may not
seem like a very big deal it may not
seem striking at all one thing that I am
in fact not interested in are the
gardens themselves I mean I'm interested
in them but for the purposes of this
talk I don't really care what they were
growing they were growing squashes and
beans what's interesting to me is not
the object what's interesting to me is
the political ecology and the political
economy of what it meant to shift the
location of that garden from one place
to another and of course I'm going to
end up talking about the modern world
and the last 400 years of capitalism so
that this story really gains its its
power from context and context that I
want to give you right away is is really
the way in which that elites in the
Atlantic world looked at progress and
how it is that this fit into that
because on the surface of it there
almost seems like a contradiction and
that is that if you would ask anybody in
fact really almost anybody on the street
today
you know tell me in one sentence about
the history of progress in the modern
world
what they're what they're likely to
launch into is something that we could
identify as the theory of stages which
is the commonplace narrative of kind of
the achievement of modernity and where
it came from and that is that people
would probably say and certainly in the
last 400 years this has been the most
popular way of understanding it that at
some point everybody was a
hunter-gatherer and they'll say that
everyone was starving and running around
the landscape and then they had this
great idea to capture animals and they
became herders agriculture came later
not because people were forced to it but
because it was a really good idea and
ultimately bang there was this social
division of labour factories a highly
commercialized society this is what they
would talk about what I can tell you and
right now you're just going to have to
trust me is that this has been enormous
ly influential so much so that for
hundreds of years before anyone
conducted any social science research
beginning in Scotland with a handful of
Scottish philosophers like David Hume
Lord Keynes I have a list these guys
that but the thing about this Stewart
that they also talked about the story
and here's what's distinctive about the
story every stage in the story supplants
the one before it
so that when people transition to
farming they didn't depend on hurting
certainly they didn't depend on hunting
when people began to earn wages they
didn't grow their own food and there was
then emerged clearly by the 17th century
an anxiety and even a hatred for the
people who did such that today again the
average person on the street
certainly not you guys would probably
conclude that someone who was a peasant
was backward primitive savages people
who were are pathetic in their isolation
and in their lack of technology who are
probably starving and who be defined as
poor I can't unpack all of this what I
want to tell you is that
this is a partial list of major
political economists from the time right
and they would have agree with James
Stewart than any person who was entirely
taken up and feeding himself depending
upon no one and having no one depending
on him if we have that we lose the idea
of society itself there's an awful lot
going into that and Stewart is much more
blunt than almost any other political
economist for why it is that peasants
must be dispossessed in order for there
to be a modern industrial society the
point is that once you have that society
people don't grow their own food any
more according to this idea they
predicted the end of self provisioning
no the other context for this and this
is what they were all talking about of
course is is enclosure in Britain
British enclosure what's so interesting
though about the process of enclosure
which created the very first legally
constituted private property in which
Lords successfully attained acts of
parliament that took the common lands of
England ejected the peasants and made it
into private property the peasants thing
could be hired back as wage labourers or
they could go to the cities and work in
factories but the thing is the thing
about the lords is that they never
intended that the peasants would give up
self-provisioning they had a different
idea in some ways they had a more subtle
idea and that is that the peasant garden
in some ways the peasant farm didn't
have to be eliminated
it could be captured that there would be
a way in which people could be asked
these wage Labor's could be asked to
produce their own food not to produce
their autonomy or to reproduce the
peasant household but in fact to
reproduce capital that they that the the
garden could exist within the cycle the
circuit of capital now actually I should
go back to the political condoms because
in fact some of them did notice this and
Adam Smith you know comes right out with
it and says
they're still subsist in many parts of
Scotland a set of people call Cotters or
Cottagers a sort of out servants of the
landlords and farmers the usual reward
which they receive from their masters is
a house a small garden for pot herbs as
much grass as will feed a cow and
perhaps an acre or two of bad arable
land now this is like an aside for Smith
of something that in fact was a much
more major movement that for whatever
reason because of the rosy world that he
was painting he didn't notice or didn't
want to write about it I don't know
that's a different question
the thing is that this thing existed
what we're talking about are what people
commonly refer to as Cotters and
Kotter's lived in cottages and so they
raised their own foods but they labored
for wages in other words Kotter's never
had enough land that would make them
actually independent peasant farmers
that wasn't the point the point was for
them to produce their own food but their
major occupation would be as wage
laborers for the Lords as if they did
not have land so but notice something
about this there's one key thing about
this that is easy to get lost but to me
it's central and that is this entire
arrangement require the work of the
entire household this was a family
project
it's the key to its popularity in early
capitalism and why we see it on
capitalist peripheries everywhere from
britain in 1650 to west virginia in 1880
and that is that the lords understood
that the household could be forced to
labor as a collective as it did before
enclosure and the results of all this
household exploitation was to distribute
the wage of the male wager if there's
only one wage coming in right that wage
is inadequate it's not enough for anyone
to survive what the entire household
does is it makes up the difference in
the wage it subsidizes the very low pay
that they receive the benefits to the
Lord's are immense they pay out very
little in cash that people produce their
own food reproducing the labor power of
the worker who then goes to work and
produces gobs and gobs of surplus-value
or whatever he does for the Lord so the
way this worked everywhere was that
employers accumulated all of this
additional profit without paying it more
workers without extending the working
day without purchasing additional tools
because they could lower what they paid
out in cash and the workers survival was
subsidized by the entire family on a
little piece of land growing whatever
they grew by showing you this mining
household and it's an extraordinary
picture I'm getting ahead of my story
but I just want to make the connection
between the miners in southern West
Virginia in 1880 and the people the
Cotters of 1780 that it's the very same
kind of relationship okay so and they're
standing in front of their garden - so
imagine imagine how excited I was when I
found this picture um so let's move to
UM to West Virginia itself and the
difference is there's
really important differences between the
English peasantry of the 1780s and and
this American peasantry if you will of
the 1880s but what made them similar is
that the only reason that someone would
take wages is because they would lose
control of the environments that sustain
them okay the only way that you can
create an industrial workforce is to
dispossessed them of any of the material
basis that they had used before to
create their own food those people don't
need wages or they can use wages as an
attribute to the family economy as they
want to that's not something that
employers ever liked this map I show it
to you because because it was also just
such a cool find
this is one of the very first maps of
the coal trade in the United States and
you'll recognize the the border between
Maryland Virginia this would have been
West Virginia but it's 1848 West
Virginia was created in 1863 during the
Civil War and this of course is western
Pennsylvania they had no idea that most
of the coal was actually down here but
this is one of the very first attempts
to map out where this coal would be
because people were already interested
in in mineral exploration that they were
putting their very first fingers out
moving into Appalachia purchasing land
rich bottom land and this was causing
all kinds of changes in the Society of
the people who lived in the in the
upcountry in the mountains so how did
the companies gain hold of this land
they didn't try to do very much in the
1840s except to make all kinds of
purchases but after the Civil War this
really accelerated the way that they
gained hold of the hollows is
complicated and there's many different
aspects to it but to understand one of
the key ways of doing it we have to know
something about how mountain people
actually lived now this is obviously a
huge subject I can't say too much about
it but the essence of the upcountry
Appalachian household was a relationship
with the forest
that is to say without the forest it
makes no sense that the forest provided
as I try to depicted here the literal
actual spaces for fields in gardens
right so this is shifting cultivation
you shift your fields through the forest
produce in a certain place for a number
of years let it lie fallow and clear
someplace else you guys know this right
but the other thing was that the it was
a place of fuel forage foods and game
animals the forest gave all kinds of
commodities including commodities for
exchange but it didn't ask anything in
return the forest required no investment
in money it gave money in the form of
cattle but it didn't require money that
is the magic relationship without which
nothing would work and that is that in
hungry times which is always the spring
because in the spring you plant your
stuff it hasn't come up yet you've run
out of winter stores and this is when
people are hungry so gathering wild food
was essential for survival it was called
you can ask and which is a word for
foraged foods and one of the key ones
today and I believe it's a feature of
some very fancy restaurants today it's
called ramps and a ramp is an onion and
if you ever seen one it's sort of like
it's like a big scallion you know a big
green onion with an extremely you know
deep and rich flavor that would just
grow obviously it just go all over the
forest floor you you see them here I
love the word ramps and I've never heard
anyone explain where it came from my way
of thinking about it because it's an
English word is that it was a ramp
it was literally a way to get from one
part of the season to the other without
starving so you gather a huge bunch of
these plus anything else you had and you
would make a stew out of it and this is
how people live but again this is the
forest giving wild food in addition to
wild game which was absolutely essential
the thing about the forest also was that
this was for grazing the money component
of every household and these households
loved money they loved exchange they
loved markets and the thing that they
exchanged were cattle you could graze
your cattle in the mountains
you could brand them just like people
ultimately did on the Great Plains in
order for to distinguish them as
property you let him go even through the
winter even if they were attacked by
wild animals and something I'm really
interested in is why it was that they
allowed such waste right and people
speculate at the time is why they didn't
really care about the welfare of the
animals even during the wintertime but
they'd really didn't and then you gather
them up in the spring basically marched
them to say Baltimore sold them and
bought stuff this was money on the hoof
this is where cash came from I'm sure
that they ate some of it but really they
were participating in a beef and also
with pigs and a pork trade that was in
some ways the precursor of the long
drives this was money this is where
their cash came from this depended on
the forest that's my only point what the
the companies that entered Appalachia
after the Civil War were as interested
in lumber as they were in in coal and in
fact they were often the same
corporations what they understood was if
you destroy the forests you destroy the
capacity of these people to endure in
place if you wanted to buy their land
you cannot go up to a fully functioning
fully possessed agrarian household a
series of linked households across an
entire series of hollows and say give us
your land they're just gonna say you're
crazy get out of here they have to be
weakened so what they did was there's
all kinds of ways that they acquire the
rights to forests because very often the
households that used this forest did not
own the forest they used they might have
owned a certain piece of land and they
did and they wrote up because I I just
spent a summer reading their handwritten
but what they owned as land and what
they called a farm did not increase the
extensive forest that may have belonged
to someone in New York City if may not
have belong to anybody if you may have
once belonged to King George the third
they didn't care because no one was
coming by but when these companies began
to look at the deed books they began to
figure out who owned the land and this
force and where they lived and through a
variety of means some of them legal many
of them legal many of them illegal they
acquired the land and they began to cut
it so this is just four hundred thousand
acres in the 1860s 1.3 million acres in
the 1870s and on down by the 1920s the
lumber yield from Appalachia had been
about 30 billion board feet of lumber
some people say some people like to say
they cut every single tree and they
built railroad spurs into every single
Hollow I don't know about that I can
tell you that it really didn't matter
because the extent was simply phenomenal
when they cut the forests the entire
cash economy as I said just no longer
made sense BC that cash was important
because they used it to buy all kinds of
cool stuff and the things that they
could not make themselves so what these
households very often did was if the
cash income from cattle was vanishing
was disappearing that the men folk would
end up earning wages cutting the forest
itself they actually went to work
earning wages liquidating the very thing
that they depended on this is extremely
common in a periphery what else you
supposed to do right so this was um this
was the beginning when the lumber was
gone
and people needed wages again what was
awaiting them was digging out the very
minerals that they had used in their
stoves for a very long long time some of
them in fact tried to dig coal
themselves and make money off it
wasn't gonna work because of the extent
and the depth of the mines and and the
problem of engineering and these are
former Confederate engineers who had
worked for the military throughout
Appalachia both because they were West
Point trained engineers and also
cartographers there was a lot of talent
and a lot of experience from the Civil
War and it all went into the coal
companies which is where the money was
and these are the guys who knew how the
mountains worked not from local
knowledge but because they had been
there with robert e lee mapping it and
that's who came back so when the wages
were necessary there was a more or less
willing population of people who needed
those wages who were willing to go to
work for the mineral companies that is
really not the end of my story
it's actually sort of the beginning
because the households that i'm talking
about we're still using cash income to
augment their family incomes they
weren't moving down into the coal camps
because they still didn't have to
they had their gardens up there they
were hunting squirrels they were
sometimes starving they weren't happy
but they also were not down in the coal
camps i've got a great document for this
as i can't i can't share with you all my
evidence so i thought so i thought what
am i going to do and what I decided was
I tell you just a little bit about River
of Earth a fabulous novel written by
James Steele who grew up in the
mountains in the in the 1840s and it
includes this conversation between a
character named mother and the character
father and that is that they're living
up on the ridge there called the
Baldrige family and the name of the mine
is called blackjack mine right so she's
up there and she said if we had a cow
her orders would be tick tight because
they had given up all their livestock
they had no place to grant it to graze
it the forest had been completely
stripped where they lived and she said
it would be a sight the milk and butter
we'd get father is much more interested
in the possibility of wages down in the
mines
so he said won't have used for a cow at
blackjack I hear the mines are going to
open
for sure and their stock in the
storehouse we're gonna get wages they're
gonna give us food we're gonna buy food
we're gonna be fine and that's what
mother says I had a notion of staying
here and her voice small and tight I'm
again raising chaps in a coal camp all
of us getting lice and scratching the
itch can't move a garden and growing
victuals your father says they'll grow
without watching we'll keep him picked
and dug and is we're going to maintain
this garden up here don't worry we're
gonna be down there but we're gonna keep
our garden up here this was a common
model thing is that mother wants
constancy and continuity she wants wages
to be a choice she doesn't want them to
be a compulsion and she totally gets it
father wants to move the family without
giving up the beans because he also
knows that that garden ensures them
against arbitrary unemployment this
garden ensures them against arbitrary
unemployment when the mines shut down in
the winter no one is paid you're on your
own
you're going to start so keeping a
garden up in the mountains accomplished
more than one thing first of all if you
did lose your job or say you wanted to
form a union or something like that you
had retrench mint you had the place up
in the mountains where you could survive
you could you can take what you needed
you could always hunt game was
incredibly scarce fact is there are ways
of getting around this but mother and
father both know that betting everything
I'm moving down to the blackjack mine
without a garden that would be on there
beyond the reach of company managers
would be emitting would be a complete
disaster the thing is that families like
the Baldrige families did move to the
coal camps they ultimately did give up
sometimes they kept that garden way up
there and the mining managers were very
savvy this summer I read the diary of
one of the earliest mining managers so
this is the flat top coal fields the
Pocahontas coal company and he's
interviewing the mountain born workers
and he's and what he says so what do you
want the money for what do you want and
someone will say well I want to be able
to buy a couple head of cattle and then
you know and have my own farm again I
want to be able to buy my land back from
the company if they said that he
wouldn't hire them he didn't want them
using wages in order to recreate their
lost autonomy and he was blunt about it
this is can't create labor discipline
people who have a garden up in the hills
can drop tools and walk away that's not
what an industrial organization wants
you to be able to do that's not what
they're about so the mountain born
created constant problems in the first
decade or two of coal mining why did the
companies when they did move down there
why do the companies compel encourage
and sometimes compel them to produce
their own gardens behind these shanties
the first reason is just the same thing
as the English Lords this is the very
same thing and that is um I can pay you
below subsistence wages and you'll make
up the difference and this has a direct
effect on the surplus value that I can I
can create this is extremely profitable
that's just the first thing there was
another reason and it had to do with
doing business in the mountains and that
is that there was very little money in
the mountains until the into the 1950s
there was very little cash the companies
didn't want to pay out their cash
reserves as as currency know so
transportation was expensive even when
they had railroads if you're an
industrial worker and in the classic
model you live entirely on wages you
spend all of your money at the company
store the company has to report the food
the foods got to get into the mountain
somehow right well one of the things
that companies did was they issued scrip
and you've probably heard this you know
the song I owe my soul to the company
store yeah I know they really did they
owe their soul to the company store
scrip is any substitute for a legal
currency so you have to appreciate that
the incredible evil brilliant
of this system and that is that what the
companies decided to do was to pay their
workers with a little coin okay coal
would West Virginia a little coin or
this good only for merchandise in store
of southern mining company all right so
the worker would then take their wages
in the form of the scrip give it all
back to the company because the company
store is owned or allied with the
company all right and then get what they
needed to survive except it wasn't
enough for them to survive on so they
then went into debt in order to get what
they needed and the debt was placed
against future wages or labor in other
words even though this is an IOU for
labor performed the company's flipped
the relationship and it actually put all
the workers in debt to the company it's
just absolute genius in this world the
garden became another way to further
what was a cashless economy just like
sharecropping just like sharecropping
and there's many example there's many
similarities of sharecropping when the
system really worked no money changed
hands oh and the garden then the garden
in the coal camp then becomes a kind of
symbol of the cashless economy because
what are you doing you're producing food
as a substitute for wages so that's the
second thing there is a third thing by
the way these are prize-winning gardens
in in coal camps they are mighty
impressive Gardens I think this is just
incredible this is the first prize but I
don't think we get to see the whole
thing just look at the density and it
was often said of the people of the
mountains I've said it that they favored
a land extensive system and that they
weren't really capable of the kind of
agricultural intensification that would
go along with an increase in population
that they didn't respond to that and
some of them didn't respond to it but
when you see these gardens now some of
these might not be mountain born because
by this time we're talking about people
from Central Europe African Americans
from the south
talking about a lot of different
dispossessed garden people who are now
living in these camps and I can't tell
you who on this garden but the beans the
squashes the corn all of this are beans
growing up around these doorways right
and these that's bushels and bushels of
beans if you've ever grown these they're
unbelievably productive and then like
look at this was just like over it just
covered with beans corn and in others
you get these giant squash plants this
was an incredible amount of food and I
was in West Virginia this summer and
drove around McDowell County which is
which is where a lot of this is and I
just saw the most incredible gardens
that people still had like a half an
acre and when I would talk to people
there and they would say we produce so
much we can't consume it and we can't
give it away because everybody's got
Gardens you can't you know give squash
to someone to grow squash so it's just
this overabundance of stuff that they
still that they still produce so and
this is just it's another set of
photographs from the Library of Congress
and I just had an earlier version of
this I just pointed out the different
products there was very rarely was there
actually large livestock but chickens
just for the reasons that they're
popular today in cities like New Haven
chickens were very popular because it's
it's because for obvious reasons it you
can feed a table scraps it produces meat
and it produces eggs in a very small
area so this is the backyard of a mining
shanty but here's the thing there's also
embedded in there the third thing for
why the companies encouraged it was
there was a great deal of social control
built into it as well so now you live in
the camp you live in the coal camp or
the colliery village and you've got your
mind behind your shanty and you pay rent
on the shanty oh that's the other thing
you pay rent to the company for where
you live now let's just say that you
want to join the United Mine Workers
because they came through and you had a
meeting and the management warned you
not to go
the meeting and you just said go to hell
I'm going to the meeting and you go to
the meeting and you want to form one of
those radical unions in the United
States and you join the United Mine
Workers and then you decide that it's
intolerable you've got no control over
your working environment you're not paid
anything you're gonna go out and strike
the company says it's fine you're hereby
evicted from your house but if I evict
you from the house I Invicta from the
garden in the nineteen twelve Paint
Creek Cabin Creek strike the company
first evicted all the miners along the
canal wha River from their homes and
then placed a private guard force all
around the mining camps specifically to
prevent miners from getting back to
their gardens they wanted the miners
wanted to steal their own chickens and
steal their own beans the company
prevented them from doing that and the
strike was conducted by starving miners
so that labor violence and labor
conflict had a subsistence element to it
right to the extent that people were
able to get family from the hills or
other people to provide them with food
or to plant their own gardens in the
Hills right then they were able to have
a separate that separate autonomous kind
of subsistence that would allow them to
fight the companies the companies trying
easily tried to shut that down so we're
talking about linking the garden and the
home together and evicting people from
both that was a degree of social control
so one guy I found this in the United
Mine Workers journal in the 1890s there
was a former mining labor official and
he went down to the canal River right
near Charleston he met a guy named Tom
Ferry and they're looking around and the
the ex-secretary McBride said I have
advocated giving the miners patches of
ground so that their idle time
utilize in providing some of the
necessaries of life to keep the wolf
from the door and noticing that the
plough or Spade was used on every bit of
available land along the Kanagawa River
because this guy was from Indiana and I
mentioned the fact to tom ferry saying
at the time the people must be very
industrious Ferry said they are a darn
sight too industrious they are so
industrious that they can dig coal for
almost nothing and McBride said his
answer sent me to thinking if the land
in West Virginia was used as an adjunct
to the puck store also known as the
pluck me store in the production of coal
how were our miners in other parts of
the country to meet this kind of
competition it's an amazing in political
economic insight right there and that is
wait a minute not only of these gardens
actually admitting the miners but by
lowering their wages their misery aiding
people all over the country because
they're setting a standard of low wages
that in fact affects people and miners
and other places and he made that
connection right there on the Kanawha in
looking at miners Gardens which on the
outside of it looked great fabulous you
know lots of food there is no doubt that
miners benefited from these gardens the
quality of their diets I mean had to be
immense
I mean ever ever have you thought of the
notion of canned bread before I mean
compared to the the stuff that they were
going to get you know just flour and
bacon from the company's store what they
were producing would have been something
that any of us would strongly advocate
this is fresh fruits and vegetables
right that was a major benefit another
benefit is it a tip it took a terribly
drab place and it made it more beautiful
as squash flowers will know but the
benefit as I've been trying to indicate
really belonged to the company if you
actually would calculate you know who
really was in control here a few
concluding points the company's broke
the resistance of mountain people by
importing workers from all
the world the advantages that if you
took african-americans from Mississippi
or you brought in people from Hungarians
then these people had no connection
they had no link to the mountains and
they'd had no idea where they were so
there was no way for them to attain that
that retrenchment right in ordinary
circumstances and this is one thing that
was explicitly talked about and I have
another mining manager saying we've got
to get ourselves a carload of Hungarians
a Hungarian was anybody it was anybody
who was not from the mountains was a
Hungarian the other thing that I want to
point out is that is that industrialists
like Henry Ford loved the idea of the
industrial garden here's an article one
journalist referred to Henry Ford's
gardens a shotgun gardens and you really
can't do better than that right you must
cultivate your garden what Henry Ford
said to workers at two iron mountain
which is where they made all the wooden
parts of the Model T is that if you were
a head of household and you didn't have
and you didn't plant a garden you'd be
fired if you're a single man you didn't
have to so he loved this idea that
industrial workers would produce food in
the summer and would would basically
work in the factory throughout the
winter and he was not alone
and that is as we head to the 1920s and
30s this was this was absolutely all the
rage in industrial circles and that is
that that that industrial workers would
basically do both and there be a fusion
between farm and factory that would all
go together and their model if they said
so or not was the coal mining camps it
was kind of uh you could almost imagine
a TED talk which tells you something
about what I think about that you know
this imagine a TED talk where everybody
wins you get everybody would you get
high quality fruits and vegetables and
the companies get to you know make a
higher profit and farm and factory and
it's like this environmentally green
thing is sound like a TED talk to you
yeah sure
that makes perfect sense except it's not
win-win it's just win the third thing I
want to tell you is that the government
got under this - but this is slightly
different
and then there's one thing I did not
tell you about is that there was a
benevolent form of this Kotter's garden
that also goes all the way back to early
modern England and that was the public
forum was to take unemployed people and
instead of taking public relief they
would produce their own food now this
also helped the Lord's right and that is
to say people made unemployment through
a variety of different ways would then
not be on the public rolls and they'd be
maintained as a labor army but aside
from that they weren't starving the
United States under the Roosevelts for
reasons that I cannot go into right now
also truly love this idea and in
Arthurdale West Virginia right down the
road from Morgantown there was one of
the key experiments in what was called
amazingly the division of subsistence
homesteads the idea was that the
unemployed miners in Scotts run one of
the most impoverished areas in all of
impoverished West Virginia would produce
their own this is this is how it looks
today would produce their own food in
these nicely built little houses but
they would earn wages in a general
electric general electric vacuum
cleaning factory farm and factory
notice that the plan was not for them
simply to be subsistence farmers that
was hugely controversial because it
seemed like a rejection of industrialism
and capitalism anti-modernist forces
within the administration pushed and
pushed not to have the factory but the
other forces ultimately gave in because
Congress was not going to go along with
it if it wasn't a factory there it's
like you couldn't give up the wages it
just was too radical an actual free
pleasantry was not something that anyone
in the United States was going to accept
okay I can't go into it but the factory
actually sunk the entire project but
still it was extremely interested and I
have to point out the people who grew up
at Arthurdale
loved it even though socially and
economically it didn't really work it
was not the only such place I bring it
up to you because it was a benign form
of the coal mining garden right down the
road from the coal mines so I leave you
with a few images does this exist today
the answer is I can't really tell but I
think so so here is a Timberland Factory
in Vietnam and the code of conduct
coordinator there's a term for you who
said that when the strike occurred the
manager asked me how to solve the
problem I advised him to use his own
workers instead of a food sub crocked
subcontractor to supply and serve food
for the factory and think about how to
provide healthy fresh food for their
employees there are examples of
factories using their own workers to
produce food no that's not exactly the
same thing as a household garden what's
interesting about it is the extent that
it would use labor on labor time to
produce food that the company then did
not have to purchase a lot of these
companies have cafeterias where they
serve breakfast and lunch this is in
factories all over the region to their
workers and they sometimes produce that
food and if you see this in the times
where I've seen this in the media which
has been few people would say how cool
and they're producing their own food and
this is like green and here's the top of
a textile factory producing food well
what I'm trying to present to you is
that the food may be of really high
quality there may be some advantages to
it but it's the company more than the
workers that derive that that advantage
these people very likely go home to
villages where people do produce food
today so that the villages a larger
extended family in fact do the very same
thing where households or linked
households or communities will feed them
and make up the difference with a low
wage we're talking about people being
paid you know like a dollar fifty day
and I've read cases of women scavenging
for snails and digging out garbage from
behind hotels and so it's a lot better
to be able to eat this or to have your
village take care of you but that's only
to say that this subsidizes the very
same wage so that someone can live and
can work again so I can't tell you the
actual social relationship this guard I
don't know but I can I can take a look
at the pictures and say hmm I wanted you
know I wonder what's going on here in
addition to it being a green roof and it
lowers the heating cost and right you
probably know all kinds of reasons for
why this is like ecologically but
there's this other political economy
that may be hidden from it so um that's
really all I have to say it's just that
all of this is part of a larger project
where I'm really interested in how it is
that that the most successful
institution in human history the
agrarian household the largest class in
human history more human beings lived as
part of agrarian households than have
lived the way that we do or as
hunter-gatherers it's the largest single
class and in the last 400 years in
certain societies it came to be seen as
backward primitive savage and had to be
eliminated I just find it really curious
looking at it in a more anthropological
way than historians usually do to ask
the question how is it that this
happened where did this perception come
from and how did dispossessing people
turn into a form of progress
how could poverty be progress and yet we
find again and again the different
notions of poverty were the same thing
as as progress I just find that curious
and so I'm writing a book that's about
that but specifically about Appalachia
to try to understand it and maybe if I
can to make the argument that peasant
households could be a key to
international development
and not and not an impediment any
questions I have always wanted to meet
one of these Brooklyn hipster farmers
I've not yet did that like we're all
black I've always wanted to meet them
but no no no I mean I'm in favor of it I
mean obviously it's it's great and I
know people at Fordham who have been
involved in urban agriculture I mean I
have nothing to say to say about it in
in this in this political economy one
larger question would be when we produce
our own gardens are we subsidizing our
wages and it's kind of hard to make that
argument that my garden would prevent me
from demanding higher wages from foreign
and which I'm not likely to get but no I
don't I don't
one complaint is is the food just going
to restaurants I mean is it is it is it
going to a larger community but it's
hardly a complaint if you're using an
abandoned lot and you're producing food
with it because I see it from the Train
I see it in the seed in the Bronx
I have students writing about it and in
some cases these are community gardens
and housing projects I just think this
can only be a good thing
in Latin America during the mid 20th
century and its really fascinating how
you talked about the New Deal and
industrialists to have a lot of this and
the work I'm doing gets carried to Latin
America and it's used as sort of the
United States these same same people
saying ideas being being carried down
there I have two questions that thinking
about that one is in West Virginia and
the case you're studying did you ever
come across social unrest about erosion
and access to fertile land because in
the case that I'm studying there's a lot
of tension over the monopolization of
the fertile bottomlands under the West
Virginia case would be the coal
companies and farming and my second
question is if you come across any
economies of scale
take advantage of with the Nestle plant
did the individual smallholders maintain
control over their own property sort of
like the rubber tappers that michael
dove writes about I say I see because if
people are possession of their land and
they make money selling their cacao
that's cool with me you know but you
know the the the story of this mountain
culture is itself a group of people who
were basically fleeing the planters you
know in like this in the 1730's 40s 50s
and when the capital moved in when
capital moved into Appalachia right
after the American Revolution all of
these people in New York and Baltimore
and other places who maybe didn't even
visit the mountains were buying up that
that for the bottom line George
Washington is the best example right
Washington would hire surveyors and said
if you're caught on the other side of
the proclamation line this never this
conversation never happened
right and they would go and they would
survey
beautiful pieces of bottomland in West
Virginia and he would say that's mine
and so these the other people it was
push and pull they were pushed into the
mountains but they were also really good
mountain farmers so it's a little hard
to tease it apart I'm fascinated by this
notion of people fleeing up to the
mountains because obviously if you're
gonna farm on an incline you could
create terrible erosion they were known
for just being really good at producing
you know nearly vertical fields that's
hilarious but poor people end up in the
mountains and sometimes those mountains
gives them could protect protection and
sometimes they find ways integrated ways
of living in the mountains but other
times that's just a sign of their
poverty is that they're forced onto the
worst land with Appalachia it's kind of
hard to tell
because if they had that force and they
had their cattle and they made their
money they were okay for like a century
well Immanuel Wallerstein
this is this is not something that you
see industrial workers doing in the
middle of cities I mean I'm not saying
they don't produce food in slums they do
but this is really definitive of a
capitalist periphery because the way I
started and I make a bigger deal about
this in the book is that one thing that
the employer's benefited from then and I
imagine that Chinese employers do now is
that the people who they're employing
were until recently living in peasant
households so that they already
understand how to self exploit how to
work together in order to survive
regardless of how much labor they expend
that this is something that they're
capitalizing on this cultural memory
that is still that is still very vibrant
at a certain point maybe it wouldn't
work anymore but I have to point out
again I don't exactly know what's
happening here
and
there are real economic benefits to this
model but it does require a company to
have enough land for people to produce
food and as China gets a denser and
denser they're gonna move to a model in
which people receive wages exclusively
this is something that China's very
worried about and what I know about it
is very limited but that one of their
biggest fears is that if there is a
downturn they have all these people
dependent on wages because they have
forced them to move from villages and
ordered in into industrial work and then
they get old or retire or their rate of
growth slows down and then you're going
to find people who are going to be
completely destitute and then China is
going to have to basically pay them what
we would call I don't know you know
unemployment insurance and so to the
extent that companies or the state can
can encourage this it's in their
interest but I can't tell you that it's
going to to survive I don't know if I've
answered your question or not
Google did you say Google they're making
food - are they providing food to their
employees instead of money instead of
wages so let's just say that Google has
a giant Community Supported farm and
says we have like the best vet reward
you're gonna have fabulous rutabaga or
whatever chard and but we want you to
accept a little bit less in pay and
we're gonna make up the difference with
food that would really be interesting
because the cost of producing that food
would come nowhere near the cash value
that they pay in wages that's what
they're doing it's true the funny thing
is that there's this thing called a rate
of exploitation and it sounds ridiculous
to say that say an NBA basketball player
would be exploited but if there's a
really really big difference between the
wage you get no matter how much you're
paid and how much value you create
you're not being paid but for a fraction
of that value even Google will be
capable of doing that and so I'm saying
right right if we just stay the same and
there's and there's no quid pro quo then
I would say how great who wouldn't want
that
what I'm just wondering is you know is
if they're substituting the food for for
money that's all if they're not then
what a great place I mean who wouldn't
want to work for Google that's in here
yeah
you get great chard but it's just
whether or not they're playing with a
mining camp model isn't their motto
don't be evil or is that over with
but the really aggressive anti-poverty
programs in a plethora of the 50s and
60s it kind of came after this way all
of these you know remember in the
depression people argued that capitalism
had failed and that it had collapsed so
there are all sorts of people in the New
Deal many of them economists who are
saying this is the way that Americans
are going to live from now on and that
is that it's a model I have a guy saying
Milbourne wilson saying this is a model
for a new American Way of life yeah
we're all going to be growing our own
food this is what this is actually a
this is a pilot program for how everyone
is going to live completely died died
gone gone and by the time you get to the
1950s you're talking about a pure
welfare if they produce food or not I
don't know but it wasn't part of of a
public policy right right and you get
some things like electricity and you
know this is the yeah thank you very
much for inviting me